[GOOGLE JINGLE PLAYING]
JASON KLEIN: So we're just
going to jump right in.
I'm Jason.
CASEY WHITE: I'm Casey.
JASON KLEIN: And we
have been best friends
since kindergarten.
CASEY WHITE: That's right.
We've been at this business
now for 18 years, best friends
since kindergarten.
We started out making movies
and mascot costumes and--
JASON KLEIN: T-shirts out
of our parents' garages.
CASEY WHITE: We were also the
Swinging Friar, the Padres
mascot for a couple years.
JASON KLEIN: This is the
elementary school playground
that Casey and I
met at in La Mesa.
CASEY WHITE: Ms.
Laramie's class.
JASON KLEIN: And as
Casey had mentioned,
we started the business sort of
out of our college dorm rooms,
and in the summers
out of my bedroom.
And we took my bed and we
shoved it in my closet.
So I slept in this,
like, crypt, basically.
And we started to reach out
to minor league baseball teams
across the country.
We spent-- gosh, write
letters for 150 clubs.
And one team got back to
us and said, we like it.
We'll buy it.
And that was the West
Tennessee Diamond Jaxx.
And growing up here in
Southern California,
we were really influenced
by going to Disneyland,
and this idea that
story telling could
be used to create experience.
And so during this first
product, we had this idea.
What if there was
this diamond miner,
and he was in the hills of
Tennessee, mining for diamonds?
And there could
be foam pickaxes.
And kids could wear
handlebar mustaches.
And so we really loved this
idea about telling stories
and immersing fans in this
creative world of the hometown
team.
CASEY WHITE: Yeah,
since then, we've
rebranded about 60 professional
sports franchises--
major league, minor league, NBA.
We've been really lucky
to work on some really
amazing projects.
We also get to work
for Nike sometimes.
We've done a bunch
of stuff for a bunch
of different
departments at Nike--
LeBron James, KD,
streetwear stuff,
Just Do It, championship rings.
And yeah, they're a really
fun client to work for.
Yeah, World Record Breaker.
JASON KLEIN: So "Welcome
to the Circus Business"
is the title of our talk.
And the world that we operate
in is very non-traditional.
It's not your traditional
sports business.
It's the minor league
baseball business.
And the thing about
minor league baseball
is that the minor league teams
don't control the product
on the field.
So all of the talent is paid
for by a major league team.
They play and control players.
So a game goes on whether
the fans show up or not.
That part of the business
is completely separate.
So the minor league
baseball owner--
you're in charge
of merchandising,
you're in charge of
concessions, you're
in charge of sponsorship.
And in the early days of
minor league baseball,
it was just baseball fans.
And then someone said, if
we give away a rally towel,
maybe someone will come
out just because they
want a rally towel.
And then they started giving
away other stuff, like,
giving away cars so
people would come out.
And they'd have these dizzy bat
races, and all this goofy stuff
that happened on the field.
And that was really
a paradigm shift,
because now, 80% of minor
league fans come out to a game,
have no idea who's playing.
They have no idea
who the score is--
or what the score is.
They have no idea who won.
And so we're really in
charge of creating experience
for everything off the field.
CASEY WHITE: And we like to say
it's a party when a baseball
game broke out.
JASON KLEIN: So it is a very
different mindset of thinking
in the business model.
So this is Reading,
Pennsylvania.
They had a mascot band.
They don't just have one mascot.
They have five mascots.
They play at every game.
CASEY WHITE: It's
an amazing band.
JASON KLEIN: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
CASEY WHITE: It really is.
JASON KLEIN: And this is one of
their mascots, the crazy hotdog
vendor.
And it's a guy that
rides an ostrich.
And in the fourth
inning, he throws hotdogs
and hurls them into the crowd.
And the crazy hotdog
vendor is more
famous than any player that has
ever come through that team.
And to give you an
idea, kids at Halloween
don't want to dress up like
SpongeBob or like Batman.
They want to be
crazy hotdog vendor.
And so they are fans.
There are more fans of
the mascot at the ballpark
than they are of the team.
And this is a bunch
of crazy hotdog vendor
costumes, homemade.
There's an inflatable costume.
There's the real
crazy hotdog vendor.
Even the adults get in on it.
CASEY WHITE: I love
these homemade ones.
They're amazing.
JASON KLEIN: This kid
is just totally out.
CASEY WHITE: Living the dream.
JASON KLEIN: Yeah.
And to go a step further,
the players actually
wear the costume of the mascot.
So it just goes to show the
power of the entertainment
part of this business and how
it influences the game so much,
as opposed to the game
influencing the entertainment
business.
And so when we were developing
some new logos for this team,
we were thinking, how do we
take this idea of this ostrich?
And their team name's
called the Fightins.
And so we're, like, yeah,
the Fightin's an ostrich.
And we came up with
this cap design,
which is a fighting ostrich.
And that's what the
team wears on the field.
CASEY WHITE: And then they
have live ostriches that
run around the outfield berm.
Before the game, they put
them in these horse carriages.
And so sometimes you're, like,
an ostrich go lay an egg.
It thuds into this metal crates.
It's incredible.
[LAUGHTER]
JASON KLEIN: Yes.
It is a circus business.
So we have this philosophy
that great brands
are built on great stories.
And our whole process is
about storytelling and telling
stories.
So the first step
is we pack our bags
and head from here in San
Diego on research visits.
So we've been mile deep in
a West Virginia coal mine.
And we want to be
honorary citizens.
We want to eat the local foods,
talk to the locals, take tours.
We just want to immerse
ourselves in our visit.
And of course, we
meet with staff.
So this is a staff
conference table
in Eugene, Oregon, where we
were working on a project.
CASEY WHITE: Yes, again,
it's about immersion.
It's about finding
something authentic.
So we were tasked
with having to name
the triple A for the
Padres, the El Paso team.
Which we'll call blank for now.
And so we started out
heading out to El Paso.
JASON KLEIN: Yeah.
And we did a focus group.
And fans said, oh, we don't get
respect from the rest of Texas.
We're, like, underdog.
We're feisty.
We're fiercely loyal.
We like to party.
We're kind of party animals.
So we packed our bags and
did our research visit
and spent time there.
And when we come up with
names for brands, new brands,
there's a couple criteria.
And I'll let Casey jump in.
CASEY WHITE: Yes.
So we don't like formulas.
We don't like
formulas, but we found
that these four things
are really good for naming
minor league baseball teams.
So something about our--
our research visit
is really important
because we find things
that are deep cuts
and authentic to the region.
It's all about kids.
It's all about family.
That's really, really important.
Can't be ignored-- these
minor league teams,
they're not major league teams.
They don't have
major league budgets.
They don't a big TV deal.
And so we use naming, as
we'll get into-- and we should
probably hurry up, too--
so we use the naming process
and everything to really get
a lot of attention.
And then we wanted to
inspire the fan experience.
So when you go to
the ballpark, and you
enter into El Paso's ballpark,
it should speak to El Paso.
It should speak to the
brand we're creating.
JASON KLEIN: So we
were in a parking lot.
And Casey asked me, he's,
like, what desert are we in?
I think we're in the
Chihuahuan Desert.
And we're, like, OK, feisty,
fiercely loyal, underdog.
So we had this idea
of one of the names.
And the brand eventually
became the El Paso Chihuahuas.
And so when you go into a
Chihuahuas game, you walk in,
it is Chihuahuas everywhere.
The whole experience-- it's kind
of like going to Disneyland.
The whole experience is
centered around the Chihuahuas.
They have a Wooftop Deck, which
is at the top of the ballpark
and it overlooks the
entire experience.
It's awesome.
And you can party with
your friends up there.
They have incredible food.
So they're right on the border
of Mexico, the ballpark.
And so the great--
the frutas and all the
pepper and the chili.
I ate one of these whole
pineapples when I was there,
and it was amazing.
CASEY WHITE: A few minutes
later, Jason was like,
I don't feel good.
And I was, like, because
you ate a whole pineapple.
[LAUGHTER]
JASON KLEIN: More snacks--
they got rebranded.
This is their
signature food item.
It's dog bowl nachos.
And they serve it in a dog bowl.
And they get steak nachos.
And kids take this home,
and they tell their parents.
And they demand that they want
to eat their breakfast out
of the dog bowl they
got the night before.
So that's cool.
We tried this
dogbone yard of beer,
but it had some visual
issues all over the place.
[LAUGHTER]
And we decided to
scratch that idea.
Also, we developed
Chihuahua's emoji.
So in El Paso, there's
a way of communicating.
Everybody sends emoji to each
other in their own unique way.
And so there's very
specific cultural emoji,
including their mascot, Chico.
This is the airport team store.
So the team is so
popular, they've
taken over an entire
airport team store.
And it's just-- it's an
incredible experience.
And we did that same
process of storytelling
and we bring it to other cities.
So in Richmond, they're known
as the Flying Squirrels.
Lehigh Valley created most of
the steel that built America.
And so pigiron is the raw
material to create steel.
And we flipped it and
it became the Iron Pigs.
Jumbo Shrimp in Jacksonville.
Akron is known as the
rubber capital of the world.
So this is the
Akron Rubber Ducks.
And Binghamton is the
carousel capital of the world.
So we were trying
to figure out how
to make a carousel kind of
cool and modern and edgy.
And we had this idea of this
crazy horse coming off--
breaking itself
off the carousel.
And then in New Orleans,
there's a tradition
during Mardi Gras of a cake.
And inside the cake,
there's a little baby.
It's hidden inside the cake.
And then whoever gets the
slice that has the cake in it,
that person has to
throw a party next year.
So in New Orleans, they're
called the New Orleans Baby
Cakes.
And right now we're
actually naming a team,
or helping to name the
team in Amarillo, Texas.
And these are the options--
the Boot Scooters, the Bronc
Busters, the Jerky, the Long
Haulers, and the
Sod Poodles, which
is a name for a prairie dog.
So you guys can participate,
too, if you want to jump in.
You can go to
AmarilloProBaseball.com
and cast your vote.
So making teams famous.
CASEY WHITE: So
we have a few ways
that we've found that
worked really well
to bring a lot of national
and international attention
to our clubs.
So one way is to innovate.
So we love doing firsts.
So this is the best
picture you could ever
find of Al, the Rally Tuna
in Altoona, Pennsylvania.
So he comes out of
his little hidey hole
there when they have a player
on third base, I think.
And when the Altoona Curve--
is the name of the club.
And so he's this mythical,
Sasquatchesque creature.
And so we came up
with this idea.
So the Altoona-- this
is their normal home hat
for the Altoona Curve.
But just like when
you're in Little League,
we have it to where you
can turn it inside out
and become Al the Tuna.
So this is the first
official rally cap,
official on-field rally cap.
And of course, yeah,
bring the Altoona out.
Making a splash--
so this is a project
that we did for the LA Clippers.
They taked us with creating
a new mascot for them.
And so we came up with Chuck the
Condor, the California condor.
And we want to tie it,
again, with our research,
we want to tie it
to the location.
So he's a stuntman,
a Hollywood stuntman
come to be the mascot
for the LA Clippers.
And we found it really
difficult to introduce
professional or-- sorry, big
league mascots, especially.
There's just a lot of animosity
at the big league level,
for some reason, for mascots.
So we were like, well,
let's instantly ingratiate
Chuck with the fans.
So we made a deal
with Converse there.
And then everyone that
was at that night's game
got Chuck shoes.
And Chuck has been a big hit.
And we do everything.
We create a whole back story for
them to help them introduce it.
Everything to sort of get
the city excited for Chuck.
We've got these little
California references.
Yeah, we do things like
tell his story, his origin,
and comic books, all that.
And then celebrating
hometown culture--
so we have become pretty well
known for these food identities
now.
So this is in Lehigh,
Pennsylvania, which
is right outside of Philly.
It's also the Philadelphia
Phillies affiliate.
So you can get the-- they
were the steaks for one night.
And of course, you can get it
with onions or without onions.
[LAUGHTER]
And this is the cannolis
in Staten Island,
doing the Babe Ruth pointing
for the fences pose.
This is the Rochester
Garbage Plates.
So there's this
dish in Rochester
called garbage plates.
And it is macaroni salad, hash
browns, hamburgers, chili,
onions--
JASON KLEIN: Mustard.
CASEY WHITE: You know.
JASON KLEIN: You
only eat it at 2 AM.
CASEY WHITE: Yeah,
affectionately called garbage.
Anyway, so the Garbage Plates.
This one was just unveiled.
This was the Wisconsin Brats.
JASON KLEIN: Brats.
CASEY WHITE: Brats, sorry.
JASON KLEIN: That's OK.
CASEY WHITE: And then
this one was just unveiled
yesterday, right, Monday.
So this is the Staten
Island pizza wraps.
I don't know if you guys
saw that, pizza wrap.
I was pretty excited.
And you get the hat
delivered in a pizza box.
JASON KLEIN: OK, so
another one is making sure
that you're authentic.
This is one of our
favorite stories.
There's the Spokane Indians.
And they're up in
Spokane, Washington.
They're named after the
Spokane tribe of Indians,
well before any sports
team affiliation.
And up to that point,
there were a couple
of ways to treat the whole
Native American issue.
One is, don't change the name.
So like, hey,
we're the Redskins.
We don't care what people think.
And we're the Indians.
Or the other option was to
change to something benign.
We're the Red Hawks now.
Or we're going to completely
change the name to the Black
Bears, whatever.
And so we were there working
with the Spokane Indians,
the baseball club.
And they said, hey,
whatever you do,
we can't touch the
Native American issues.
OK, that's great.
And we said, cool.
Tell us the back story.
And they said, oh, we're named
after the tribe of Indians.
We're like, do you guys have
a relationship with them?
Like, oh, yeah, they're
great friends of ours.
And so we're like,
well, could we
collaborate with
the actual tribe
on creating a brand centered
around their heritage?
And so we went up
to the reservation.
We met with the tribal elders.
And they sat-- and it was a
collaboration with them and us.
And they gifted us
the eagle feather
to be able to use
part of their brand.
And they also created
this lettering
in Salish, which is the
tribal language, that says
Spokane Indians Baseball Club.
And what's incredible is there's
only about five individuals
in the world that speak Salish.
And the amount, the percentage
of actual tribal members
in Spokane is
really, really tiny.
It's probably less than 5%.
But they've completely embraced
the ballpark experience.
So here in San Diego,
we have restrooms
in English and Spanish.
In Spokane at the ballpark,
they have English and Salish
for all the restrooms
and all the signage.
And if you think
about the-- like,
five people can speak that.
But it's a great
outreach program.
It's a great way--
third option, if you
will-- of the whole concept.
And so this is--
all the jerseys are
written in Salish.
It's the only non-English or
-Spanish team on a baseball
jersey in America.
They have great
celebration nights
where they celebrate
the whole culture.
And it's been a
great experience.
And the jersey is in the
Baseball Hall of Fame
as a result.
And yeah, so we'll
jump to the Q&A.
CASEY WHITE: OK.
SPEAKER 1: So before
I start, are there
any questions from anybody in
the room for Jason or Casey?
JASON KLEIN: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Could you
pronounce that name?
JASON KLEIN: It's the Salish?
AUDIENCE: That says Spokane.
JASON KLEIN: It
says Spokane on it.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
JASON KLEIN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: When you guys ask a
question, can you repeat it--
JASON KLEIN: Absolutely.
Yeah, so the question--
AUDIENCE: --so that we can
hear you on television?
JASON KLEIN: Yeah,
the question was what
was the word across the jersey?
And it's the word Spokane
in the Salish language.
Great.
SPEAKER 1: Well, while we're out
in San Francisco, any questions
from the room in San Francisco?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
having dealt with
or having been on the
customer's side of going
through some
redesigns in the past,
I know how difficult and
painful that process can be,
and how many times it
takes to get it right.
How did you guys succeed?
Or how do you guys--
because, obviously, you
have a great body of work,
but how do you guys manage
those tricky engagements where
people are like, yeah,
this is not quite it.
Yeah, that's not quite it.
Those types of scenarios--
CASEY WHITE: That's
a good question.
So again, we've been
at it for 18 years.
And we're really
proud of the fact
that we've never
issued a change order.
We try to price--
we're a little
bit more expensive
than all of our clients.
So we try to price our
services at a level
in which the client
can basically put us
through the ringer and it's OK.
[LAUGHTER]
That's really the short answer.
And we sort of look at it as,
like, it all averages out.
So sometimes projects
gel really quickly
and come together
really fast and then
some drag on for years.
But we think it all
kind of averages out.
I would also say that
one trick that we use
is just to trust our process.
Our process is really strong.
And we're really
proud of our process.
And it being proven
over the years
has been beneficial to helping
to guide projects to closure.
SPEAKER 1: I really enjoyed
the walk through of the El Paso
Chihuahuas.
And I definitely understand
why those yard beer
things didn't make it.
Good idea.
So I'm sure you guys have
done a lot of other stuff
that was really clever, but just
didn't see the light of day.
What were some of your favorite
things that just never saw
the light of day?
JASON KLEIN: So we thought we
might get asked this question.
CASEY WHITE: We came prepared.
JASON KLEIN: We came prepared.
CASEY WHITE: Ideas that
never saw the light of day.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: What a coincidence.
JASON KLEIN: So this is
the Blind Cave Shrimp,
which is-- so to
give you an idea,
in Bowling Green,
Kentucky, there's
the largest underground cave
system in North America.
And there's one spot where you
could fit a whole NFL stadium
and it wouldn't touch the walls.
It's ginormous.
So they have this blind
translucent shrimp
that lives in the caves.
And in the name the team
contest, one of the contenders
was the Blind Cave Shrimp.
Ultimately, the fans
voted for the Hot Rods,
which is the team they became.
But in the back of
everybody's mind,
it was like, man, what if
we were the Cave Shrimp?
What if we were the Cave Shrimp?
And so together
with the team, we
invented the first
what could have
been night, which is a game in
which you play in the runner
up identity of a name
the team contest.
So this was the
Blind Cave Shrimp.
And it became so popular,
they stock it on shelves.
Still to this day, they sell a
ton of Blind Cave Shrimp logo
merchandise.
So this is one of those times.
AUDIENCE: So you're saying
the merchandise sells,
but the shrimp didn't?
SPEAKER 1: The question
is the merchandise sold,
but the shrimp didn't?
Don't even dignify that one.
Moving along.
So I follow you guys
on social media.
I highly recommend
you guys do, as well.
It's very entertaining
and you see these things
before they are
released, many times.
And one of the things
that I saw was that you're
shooting a TV pilot?
Anything you can
share about that?
CASEY WHITE: Yeah.
So don't you want to ask us
about our process, first?
[LAUGHTER]
Yes.
So we were approached
by a company
that produces the
show, "The Voice" to do
a pilot for a TV show.
And yes, so they made this--
what did they call it?
A pilot presentation
or something like that.
JASON KLEIN: Yeah.
CASEY WHITE: I don't know.
So they made this cool
pilot presentation.
This is one of
our favorite parts
of the process, which is--
we spent two full
days with the club,
researching, becoming
honorary citizens, as we say.
And then we get to sit in
the stands during a game
and drink a few beers and
brainstorm team name ideas.
So this is a shot from
one of those moments.
So that was last year, right?
And then this year, "E:60"
is doing a piece on us.
And it is unclear when that
will come out, but soon.
They have been very up in our
business for about a year now.
So we're pretty
excited to see it.
They spent a lot of time on it.
Yeah.
It's such a well-produced show.
I don't know if you've seen
that show, but it's phenomenal.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
So you probably get to see
a lot of interesting places
in your travels, a lot
of cool small towns,
a lot of interesting ballparks.
Which one was a
pleasant surprise
to you or one that's a
must-see minor league park?
[LAUGHTER]
CASEY WHITE: Funny
you should ask that.
SPEAKER 1: It's almost as if
we had known in advance what
the questions were going to be.
JASON KLEIN: Shh.
We're very fast at
putting up slides.
So there's a couple we
thought came straight to mind.
One is El Paso.
It's a brand new--
it's a modern park.
It's an hour flight
from here in San Diego.
It's incredible.
It's over the top.
They spent a ton of time,
energy, money, love, care
into that park.
And they just live, eat, breathe
Chihuahuas baseball there.
And then the other one, as
we've mentioned, is Reading.
Reading is your kind
of Fenway, Wrigley.
It's a classic
minor league park.
It's over 50 years old.
And so it's folksy.
It just feels like you're at a
local fair or everything's done
with so much heart there, too.
And it's just--
those are the two
experiences that I think of.
CASEY WHITE: Yes.
So Reading has become
our favorite place
to visit, which, you
know, says nobody but us.
[LAUGHTER]
They have-- did you just say
all their signs are handpainted?
There's portraits of everyone.
It feels like a time machine,
and it's still small.
They don't have a new ballpark.
They just kept adding on to it.
One of my favorite things about
it is under the bleachers--
these aluminum bleachers,
noisy, creaky, aluminum,
high school-style bleachers
they still have that run along
the first base line--
they've added all these
little carnival activities,
putt putt golf kinds of things.
So they just have
cram-packed it.
And they've built it out
of stuff from Home Depot.
Nothing is done
with any sort of--
JASON KLEIN: Architecture.
CASEY WHITE: --yeah,
it's just amazing.
And it sort of becomes this
cacophony of nostalgia.
And it's pretty fantastic.
I can't say enough
about Reading.
SPEAKER 1: So you guys, I
know from reading your bio,
you've been friends
since kindergarten.
Is that correct?
And you went to Helix
High School together.
And I think that was actually
one of your first design
successes that was accepted.
They did the logo for
Helix High School.
So having been married
for a long time myself,
I know sometimes you need
a little bit of space.
Being lifelong
friends, how is it
that you guys keep it light when
you're in business together?
JASON KLEIN: I think a lot of
it is running a fun business.
It really is.
You come to work every
day, and it is fun.
Early on, we were kind of
doing the exact same things.
We were doing, like, I'll
sketch and you sketch.
And at some point, I
remember Casey said, oh, man.
I don't want to make
any sales calls.
And I was like, oh, these
sketches, man, too much.
It was like, I'll trade you.
And so I think part of it
is knowing your strengths,
knowing what you're good at.
And you know, I try to stay
as much out of the sketching
process and let Casey let
his imagination run wild.
Yeah.
CASEY WHITE: Yeah.
I think a couple things.
One is that we've found our
own niches in the business.
I would say we
reconvene-- we both have
a hand in the direction
of the company.
But we only to have to meet
about that once a month
or something like that.
We both really share in
the same vision, I think,
of where we're headed.
And another one is,
I think, we just--
we do spend a lot
of time together.
I mean, if we both
reach our hands out,
we can touch each other's hands.
So we value our own lives, I
think, is a big part of it,
just to be honest.
But I would say the biggest
thing is that I just still
am entertained by my
relationship with Jason.
I think we still
have fun whenever
I get a chance to
brainstorm with him.
I just enjoy it.
And yeah, there is
a lot of "meshment."
We probably have more bank
accounts between the two of us
than we have with our
significant others.
So yeah, you do have to have
some boundaries, I think.
But ultimately,
as long as you're
enjoying each other
and the work, it works.
SPEAKER 1: I have a
few more questions.
But let me take a break to see
if there's one from the room?
AUDIENCE: I've got a two-part
question, out of San Francisco.
First part would be, I'm super
interested in New Orleans,
always have been.
Would love to hear the story
behind rebranding Baby Cakes.
And then the second
part would be,
are there any discounts on
beer that you can offer?
[LAUGHTER]
CASEY WHITE: Second
question first, no.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, the first one,
yeah, New Orleans
was a fascinating project.
Mostly because New Orleans
is a fascinating place.
I think it's the most
interesting city in America.
I mean, what other
city in America
can boast that it
speaks a second language
other than Spanish, right?
But yeah, it's
just very unusual.
The architecture's unusual.
The make up's unusual.
So we wanted something
that was really unusual.
It's also a major league town.
So they have the
Pelicans and the Saints.
They can support, probably,
a major league club.
But they have a
minor league club.
Well, you have to
get their attention.
In a big market like that, like
San Diego or LA or whatever,
you have to make a lot of noise.
And so we wanted something
that couldn't be ignored,
that was a stark contrast to
the Saints and the Pelicans,
these more sort of
down the middle names.
Now this is really
behind the curtain stuff.
So we wanted a different name.
Baby Cakes was one of the
names we came up with,
but we thought
that is terrifying.
We can't call them that.
But we pitched them a bunch of
names, and ultimately, the GM--
the guy that runs
the club there--
just got on his soapbox
and had one of those
Robin Williams jumping on
the desktop moments, where
he was like, I'm sick
of being ignored.
Cookie.
Cookie is amazing.
He's down in New Orleans.
I'm sick of being ignored.
And we won't take it anymore.
And we've got to go all the way.
And we've got to be Baby Cakes.
And everyone was taken aback,
and that's what we did.
So it was pretty awesome.
We're grateful that we have a
lot of really brave clients.
Because we do-- we
actually measure
the success of a project, like
a Baby Cakes or Chihuahuas,
by how much hate email we get.
If we get a lot of hate
mail, we're like, wow.
They're going to sell
a lot of merchandise.
That's really good.
But yeah, they have to put up
with a lot more than we do.
JASON KLEIN: People
always ask us,
isn't it the worst when
people hate what you guys do?
We say, no, the
worst thing is when
they're apathetic about it.
These teams like
Casey alluded to,
they don't have millions
of dollars in ad revenue.
So we have to find ways
to make the headlines
without a lot of ad spend.
And we always want to make
sure that it's authentic.
Is it authentic?
Can it be tied back?
The team cake that the
baby's coming out of,
is it authentic
in all its glory?
Is the lettering
authentic to New Orleans?
So we're always
thinking about that.
AUDIENCE: What were
some of the other names
that you were going between
for that particular city?
JASON KLEIN: There was the
Red Eyes, the Tailgators.
CASEY WHITE: Give some context.
We should give
them some context.
JASON KLEIN: Yeah, Red
Eyes was the late nights
in New Orleans combined with--
what was it-- crawfish.
CASEY WHITE: Right.
JASON KLEIN: Crawfish.
We had cool ideas.
We thought, what if
the uniforms were
made of newspaper, like
print, so the crawfish
are wrapped in newspaper.
It would be cool to have a logo.
CASEY WHITE: Because
people dump the crawfish--
JASON KLEIN: Yeah, they
dump the crawfish boil.
We had the Tailgators,
alligator tailgating.
We had the Night Owls--
was another favorite.
The Po' Boys, the
Po' Boys sandwich
was another name that
was in that contest.
And the Baby Cakes--
SPEAKER 1: That's great.
Thanks, guys.
AUDIENCE: You're going to
talk a lot about your process.
But do you guys do any
testing about-- once you've
got the brand name or the
logo, kind of concept theme,
do you guys go outside of you
two and the individual team
management to see what
consumers' reaction is?
SPEAKER 1: So the question
was, after you come up
with a concept,
how do you vet it
with the customer or the team?
CASEY WHITE: So we are
really against focus groups.
Yeah.
It's not just our decision.
I think that we
have this reputation
of being these crazy guys that
name these teams crazy names.
And we are that and we do that.
But we don't saddle anybody with
a name that they don't want.
It's not our decision.
It's their decision.
We have a bunch of private
schools, and at least 25%
of them are going with the
very straight down the middle,
more big league-esque name.
And we're totally
fine with that.
If that's the style of
product that they want
to put out there, we get it.
We're naming teams for
most operators, guys
that run the clubs that are
giving away free vasectomies
and doing on-the-field
colonoscopies for colon cancer
night.
And it's a pretty
crazy business.
It's a circus business.
So the name should
reflect that, right?
You shouldn't be the
Brown Bears if you're
doing craziness like that.
SPEAKER 1: Speaking
of craziness,
you guys have come up with some
pretty incredible concepts.
Has there ever been
one that's been brought
to you, a suggested
project that you just
said, we can't do that?
CASEY WHITE: Not where
we couldn't do that.
I mean, I'm regularly scared
of a project-- regularly.
In fact, there's a
right amount of scared.
And I'm even questioning
if there's, like,
even an any amount of
scared for a project.
Like, we don't know where
the ceiling is for craziness,
to be honest.
And the league and
all the operators
seem to be really
willing to go with us.
And so we're excited and
really scared about how nuts
we can get.
This year there's
some really crazy ones
that we're excited about.
But as far as, like,
we've never turned down
a project because of political
reasons or anything like that.
Again, it's a fun business.
Everyone is out to have fun.
If there's a project
that we don't want,
I would say the
only thing I would
say about that is we maybe bid
it way too high so that if we
do get it, it's not as painful.
[LAUGHTER]
That's rare, though.
SPEAKER 1: So you've alluded
to your process a few times.
And I have a feeling there
may be a slide in there that
describes your process.
If not--
CASEY WHITE: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: Yes?
So yeah, if you don't mind--
you talked a little bit
about becoming local citizens
for a couple of days,
really understanding
the local history.
I've seen some of sketches on
your behind-the-scenes process
on your website.
But if one of you
could take us through.
JASON KLEIN: Yeah.
Yeah, so this project was
just unveiled on Monday.
And it is for the Staten
Island Pizza Rats, which is--
so there was a name the team
contest a couple of years ago
for the team in Staten Island.
And they had fans vote.
And they remained the
Staten Island Yankees,
the major league
namesake, the past year.
But they thought, you know what?
Pizza Rats got the most votes.
At least for five games this
year, let's take the field
and we'll go as the Pizza Rats.
Once we do we do our
visit, we come back
and we hit the drawing board.
And so Casey gets sort of
in it and just sketches,
and just comes up
with different ways
that we could represent pizza
and rats and New York City.
And there's some
subway token stuff.
And there are some early ideas
that combined the Yankees
NY with a pizza slice.
And at this point, it's really
important for us, I think--
and somebody asked how
we get client buy in--
is we just all agree on
the criteria, the mindset.
We don't have an agenda
about how we get there.
We just say, like, oh,
we can't be ignored.
We need to be authentic.
We need to tell a story.
And let's figure out how we're
going to go about doing that.
And as long as everybody
at the top level
has bought into the
process, we don't even
know where it's going to go.
Or it's, like, let's throw the
ideas at the wall, and just
sort of shepherd this thing
along and see where it ends.
So after we do sketches
and we have direction,
then we get into digital.
Sometimes there's
some happy accidents.
Like, the club said, you know,
that slice looks, actually,
like the shape of Staten Island.
And so, well,
that's a great idea.
So we sort of
massaged that into--
the pizza slice into the
shape of Staten Island-- which
is an Easter egg that nobody's
picked up on yet this week.
CASEY WHITE: So just talking
about authenticity again--
so, again, the shape of Staten
Island for the Staten Island
mark.
This is a reference to an old
New York City subway token,
the NYC with the Y in there.
And then, of course, like
any respectable New Yorker,
you fold your slice to eat it.
So our rat chef there
is folding the slice.
Yeah, so then, after digital--
JASON KLEIN: After digital,
we go into swatches.
So we put together
the spec sheets
for New Era, who's the
official cap of minor league
and major league baseball.
And there's certain limitations
to the type of colors you have,
what you can do with embroidery.
One thing that we
really pioneered
was treating embroidery
like sculpture.
So instead of just
embroidering something,
we'll break out-- this
is a great example,
you can see-- we'll break out
the sections of how we want
to lay down a single color.
So in this sort of gray
color here, we'll say,
we're going to center this here.
We want this laid down this way.
And when you have 3D logos,
where basically they put foam
underneath, and they can raise
up logos like you've seen,
it is interesting.
Because you have
different levels of foam,
so there's different
levels of how high it is.
And then how you lay down the
thread, the type of thread
that you lay down, the colors.
So we treat it like sculpture.
And then once we approve the
swatches, we get into uniforms.
And uniforms has its own
particularities about them.
And we try to push the
envelope a little bit there.
But yeah.
SPEAKER 1: That's pretty cool.
Looking at your
sketches, Casey, too, it
seems like a lot of
what you do is almost
all worldly-- letterpress
day sort of stuff.
How does technology
factor into what you do,
and has it changed your approach
to creating or promoting
your work?
CASEY WHITE: So
technology is really big.
We're quick to adopt
new technologies.
We're still a really
small firm, so we
try to use all the project
management stuff that we can.
We have a group of
people that work for us,
but they're all over the world.
Because what we
do is so specific.
It's hard to find people that--
even talented graphic designers
can't emulate our exact thing
that we're going for.
But yeah, so I
mean, social media--
we're kind of new to this.
I would say Jason doubled
down on social media
maybe a year ago,
something like that.
But he's having fun with it.
And it's been really cool
to be able to control
a bit of our message about us.
So that's been really fun.
And then we actually have
a technology company.
So a few years ago, some clubs
got together and asked us
if they were to build an app
for minor league baseball-- you
know our business.
And so we formed this
company called Grandiose Ops,
and we built an app for
minor league baseball.
We have the contract with BAM.
So Baseball Advanced Media
is the technology arm
of Major League Baseball.
They're really
great to work with.
But yeah, so we built an app
for them three years ago.
Now we're building
some new software,
actually, we're really,
really excited about.
And I can't get into
what it's going to do,
but it's going to help the
clubs run their show, basically.
And we have this thing
called the idea bar, which
is a place for people
to come and share
ideas about the industry.
That's really cool.
And so this is actually funny.
So we tried to take that same
philosophy of naming something
crazy to technology.
So this is a new product
called the Fairy Fan Father.
And basically,
it's a delivery app
for delivering candy and
beer to the ballpark.
But we're like, we should name
it Delivery Boy or something
you'd think out of the gate.
Let's name it something
crazy, like we
do for our baseball teams.
And so we had this idea
of this Fairy Fan Father,
that he grants your wishes.
He runs around the ballpark
making all your cotton candy
and beer dreams come true,
raining beer and cotton
candy on you.
So yes, so that was how
we took it to the market.
So it's just an app.
But we're seeing how
that naming process,
creative process
works in technology.
We'll keep you posted.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
Actually, I've had it recently,
and cotton candy and beer
is a great flavor combination.
[LAUGHTER]
I think we have time
for one more question.
AUDIENCE: Is there a story
behind the name Grandiose?
SPEAKER 1: The question is, is
there a story behind the name
Grandiose?
JASON KLEIN: So when we first
started off in our college dorm
rooms, we had this
idea that people
who came to us, to work
with us, that they didn't
like what they were doing.
And that they wanted to
a sort of second option.
So we started off
as Plan B Branding.
A lot of other
Plan Bs came along.
[LAUGHTER]
And when you call
somebody saying,
hey, it's Jason from Plan B,
people get a little nervous.
So at some point, we
decided maybe it's time
to switch it up, evolve.
And we sort of outgrew this
idea of being a second option
creative group.
And we wanted something that
represented us being larger
than life, with some whimsy
and some magic to it,
and going back to our
roots of storytelling
and being kind of over the top.
So we made up a word.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
Well, I think we're
running out of time.
I'd like to thank everybody
here and everybody here
who dialed in from various
cities around the country.
Thanks very much for
your questions, as well.
I would encourage everybody to
follow Grandiose on Twitter.
They do some stuff
on LinkedIn, as well.
And just to check
out their work.
So thanks again.
I really appreciate you, Casey
and Jason, stopping by today,
and hope you enjoyed this talk.
[APPLAUSE]